searching is directed by Aneesh Chacon
tea and stars John Show as a father
searching for his missing daughter he
teams up with the detective played by
Debra Messing and this story is told
from the unique perspective of his
daughter's laptop he breaks in there and
tries to find evidence to figure out
where she went if she's okay if she's
still alive did someone abduct her this
film really surprised me I didn't know
what to expect going in I had heard some
good things about it and I was floored
by the craft on display by how much I
was into the characters by how much I
was invested in this story this movie is
one of the biggest surprises of the year
for me because I've seen a few films
that are told from this perspective the
unfriended movies the den but this is
easily the best by far the best that has
used this tactic in filmmaking where
other films have used this perspective
before they tried to go for a very
authentic feel while still having
jump-scare sound effects included which
always takes you out of the experience
this film from the very beginning has a
musical score it lets you know it's a
fictional narrative and despite that it
feels very real they paid money to use
the Google name the Facebook name you
know the apps that are used the way
they're used the sounds it's all
extremely realistic it opens with
experiencing this family's past story
through the computer and we see the old
windows programs from back in the day
Microsoft Paint and spam emails and all
kinds of things like that that was very
nostalgic for the first few minutes but
I found myself genuinely caring about
this family which is so important
because so much of the film is the
father and his frustration with not
being able to find this girl and John
Cho is magnificent I love him in every
film I've seen him and if you didn't see
Columbus really great film very
overlooked last year shegaon t utilizes
what some might call a conventional
narrative but it's the way he tells his
story that makes it feel fresh you
understand thoughts that are going on in
people's heads because they type out a
text and then decide you know what I'm
gonna delete that because I don't want
to share that information right now so
we do that in real life sometimes when
we're texting our friends or our family
we'll want to say something and though
delete delete delete lead never mind and
you learn kind of the frustration that's
going on in his brain through actions
like that but he also uses a simulated
handheld look for the computer screen
sometimes you'll see it bouncing up ever
so slightly and it never feels like a
distraction but it makes it feel a lot
more theatrical and he does something
with his story that I loved and I found
super relevant he has smaller characters
that knew this girl and as the father
was trying to reach out to these guys
and girls they're like yeah she was okay
I didn't really talk to her that much
sorry
can't really help you and you see him
get angry and he feels very lost later
in the film when this girl's
disappearance becomes public news and
it's trending and everyone's talking
about it you see these same characters
are making videos about her crying
talking about how much they loved her
and you realized the hypocrisy sometimes
in people when something becomes popular
and they want to support it when they
didn't really care about it before but
now it's popular and I love this film
explored that because I haven't seen too
many films with the balls to say
something like that and this film did
and one last thing before I grade it
this film actually really inspired me as
someone who's been making short films
since he was 14 and been talking about
movies online for almost a decade now
this movie inspired me I noticed in the
film when one of the characters goes on
Facebook M night Shyamalan s name is
trending in the movie I thought to
myself that that's not a mistake that's
in there for a reason so I did a little
research on mr. Joe Gatti and I saw that
he was just like me very inspired by M
night Shyamalan as a kid and spent most
of his youth making short films with no
money just like me and right now I'm
currently trying to get a feature made
and doing meetings and pitches and stuff
with with various studios and so I just
want to say if by any chance you're
watching mr. Chuck on T thank you for
the inspiration because I get it I feel
it and you made a great movie and I
can't wait to see what else you do I'm
gonna give searching and a I was really
invested in this movie and towards the
last 15 to 20 minutes as there were a
lot of things happening and there was a
lot of stuff to process
so I was pretty much glued to my seat I
really enjoyed it if you want to support
a film made by a filmmaker who has
always wanted to make a film and who did
a really damn good job with us first
outing please go see searching it's
worth your time guys thank you so much
as always for watching look forward to
more reviews very soon if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]
you